messieurs le temps
nouvel album dès les tous inédits de
michèle torr nous serons en domitienne
en pension bâtiment qu'elle
voilà est le premier single c'est ça
ces données
là avec eux
ce tollé
affaire
oh
michèle torr à la bonne elle a beaucoup
donné
michel donc cet album ce single une
tournée dans toute la france et
l'olympia du 12 au 17 novembre 2002
c'est votre salle fétiche même s'il
était racheté par jean marie messier ol
reste pour moi la salle mythique la
salle habité par toutes les parts ou les
plus grands la salle de l'olympia de
bruno coquette et ouais ouais alors
votre premier olympia c'était en 1964 1
oui en lever de rideau de claude
françois
17 ans un trac fou oui des nichons
superbe mais plus beau jeu de la côte
d'azur un michel wii wii est un jeu où
il y avait jean joseph kessel quand même
oui c'est pas rien c'est pas rien alors
à l'époque de le premier olympia donc à
17 ans des trois chansons pour preuve un
complice et des terribles sac à main et
puis et puis quand je quand je suis
monté quand je suis arrivé sur scène et
que j'ai vu au premier rang jean claude
brialy qui me qui me portait qui était
enfin le c'était le trac était étaient
passés les socialistes et quelques lots
il vous reprochez de rouler un peu trop
les airs un we use of the truth vibrato
il trouvait aussi trouvé j'ai les
produits brac torse avait des chocs
c'était très confidentiel ce alors votre
maire avait rêvé de devenir une
chanteuse elle était même pressenti par
jean nohain pour chanter un marseille
dans un radio crochet mètres en mer n'a
jamais voulu être pensé que c'était pas
un métier respectable elle avait
peut-être raison c'est qu'il y ait des
pdf vous un petit peu il
donc enfant précoce puisque envie de
chanter transmises par votre mère et par
piaf et vous gagnez votre premier radio
crochet à courthézon à l'âge de 6 ans
oui au casino cinéma de courtes et je
vais chanter bonbons caramels s kimouche
common cannelle eskimos chocolat je ne
suis pas très ému finalement un
président alors maintenant on n'a pas
peur quand on est tout petit on apprend
the rye en doutent de rien on est sûr de
soi et j'avais aucun doute je devrais je
devais de chanteuse dans mon père donc
il travaillait à la poste il voulait
monter en grade chez les postiers et de
temps en temps on était obligé de venir
à paris pour passer des concours et à un
moment vos parents viennent habiter
quelques temps à à paris et quand il
manque d'argent vous persuader votre
mère de vous conduire dans une brasserie
place d'italie ce mois ci serait louey
mais c'est fou m
et
merci les enfants merci beaucoup pour
vos parents à parler de montée de
l'argent aux personnes et votre mère de
nous conduire dans une brasserie place
d'italie où avait lieu un radio crochet
alors à décrocher permanent et vous
gagnez assez souvent
j'arrivais très naïvement sans partition
rien de moins et donc on dit qu'est ce
que vous chantez bon je chantais déjà du
vin déjà un gentil du piège de pia
domino chantier bouger chanter domino et
de mios et télé parce que vous chantiez
chez les bonnes soeurs célébrant de
dominos et hérite ces dominos dossiers
chauds j'ai besoin d'être aimée domino
si les voitures sont fabriquées en tous
les cas dont xavier 11 ans à l'époque et
ça permettait à vos parents de s'acheter
à manger il faut bien le dire parce que
la vie y était et est pas simple pour
vous à 14 ans vous êtes viré de l'école
j'étais bien vite faire l'école à quoi
ressemblent les gens des fois ils
m'appellent pour me demander qu'est ce
que je faisais et vous remporter un
concours qui s'appelait on chante dans
mon quartier avignon des plats votre
père était avignon est donc le premier
prix c'était de faire la première partie
de la tournée de jacques brel jacques
brel à travers part qui demande en
hausse - oui dans la cour du palais des
papes
tout a failli s'arrêter à ce moment là
ça a été ça a été les motions de ma vie
j'ai jamais rien vu d'aussi
extraordinaire
j'ai vu un géant sur scène qui se donner
complètement et donc j'étais ému bien
sûr et puis malheureuse parce que tout
s'écroule et ce jour là à penser je ne
pourrais pas faire ce métier
voilà et là évidemment vous êtes mûr
pour monter à paris vous faites ça l'âge
de 16 ans avec madame bio de son
audition c'est félix et à leur coup de
bol comme quoi dans la vie c'est insensé
c'est faux le directeur le pdg monsieur
hazan un suave et bien oui oui il reçoit
deux disques souples un disque souffre
d'une chanteuse qui avait déjà fait un
premier masque et qu'ils aient donc une
maquette pour son second disque et puis
lumière et puis l'ingénieur du son s'est
trompé de nom et donc ils écoutent ils
écoutent agnès et agnès fontaine qui est
devenu peintre maintenant et donc ils
écoutent agnès et puis d'antan ym entend
donc j'étais exodus non je n'en resterai
il m'a l'air et vous devenez une
incontournable de la vague yéyé cela que
j'ai découvert - sur le transistor
plusieurs de mes parents à toute la
famille s'installe à paris à ce moment
là oui votre père toujours la poste oui
oui quand même on sait jamais il va pas
et monte pas monter tout de suite on
avec ma maman ma petite soeur s'est
installée dans la rue bergère 6e étage
et pas pallié nous rejoindre en vélo
c'est dingue où est donc le premier
olympia avec le clou là la tournée d'été
et la dram vous offrez à votre mère go
premier cachet une automobile est
soutenu à la première va dire oui
gt gt à marseille justement avec l'autre
françois ont chanté à l'alcazar c'était
les fêtes de fin d'année
et voilà et ses alliances de votre maman
hôtels autour du coup là alors là vous
tombée amoureuse du chanteur christophe
il vous fait un enfant et il disparaît
sans reconnaître
ah oui il avait jamais vu il a une
excuse coup dur aussi un sérieux pas
vraiment non parce que parce qu'avoir un
enfant c'est une belle chose qui puisse
arriver
et c'était
j'ai l'impression mon fils m'a sauvé
plutôt de et non c'était c'était le plus
grand bonheur qui pouvait m'arriver dans
le village jez et là bas quand même oui
oui oui la pomponnette on appelait donc
christophe n'a n'a jamais revu son fils
et vous vous lavez revue christophe non
on se croise très très peu très peu
la f10 dossier des trappeurs qu'il
allume un autre jour on évite de les
inviter lé même jour toujours pareil
bien et là alors l'air et on va pas
invité non n'arrivera pas on peut la mi
temps vous aurez pu inviter aussi
également moi je me donnais pas des
idées comme ça parce que c'est ça qu'il
faut pas beaucoup m'amuser et c'est là
que votre maison de disque que vous vire
c'est vrai mais ça a été ça a été le
l'électrochoc est très très bon voilà
très bon parce que ça m'a fait réagir je
dis quoi comment mais moi qui chante si
bien qu'ils aient tellement de talent
mais comment ils ont rien compris et ça
m'a fait beaucoup de bien
vous êtes revenu est revenu avec je
m'appelle michel avec une petite
française vous souvenez de ça une petite
française à l'eurovision